jamison tyone is on the mound two starts
eight in the third innings he's struck
out ten walk one opponent sitting three
fourteen against him in an era of seven
point five six a-ray adrianza a switch
into batting left swing and a miss
one away darno it's a high fly ball to
left center not deep talkman comes in to
make the catch no runs one hit and one
left now at the end of a half the braves
nothing yankees are coming about charlie
morton who knows all about the yankees
in his big league career jeff yeah a lot
of great success against the yankees
especially since 2018.
see those numbers averaging 12.6
strikeouts per nine innings and last
year faced him in the alds out in san
diego went five innings one earned run
six caves but charlie's big thing he's
got to stay away from that one inning so
one away and here is judge that one's
driven deep to left center field
heredia is there that ball didn't travel
at all kind of died as heredia
runs it down
two down for brett gardner see you later
swung on and missed good fastball 96
and down they go one two three
they'll be facing four five and six here
in a second there it is again
back-to-back strikeouts and the blue
birds are out in the second inning in
new york new york's one of the best
places to play when you're going well
one of the worst when you're going bad
braves have their second base hit the
man in scoring position for ada adrianza
no score in the top of the third inning
and that's sent out towards right field
and a base hit down the line this will
go all the way to the wall rounding
third coming into scores aradia
one-nothing braves ayday adrianza mixes
it up and back-to-back doubles make it a
one-nothing atlanta advantage got ready
for that fastball again three-two this
one down a little bit more
that's a beautiful swing on it
no chance for a judge to do more than
pick it up and throw it into second base
even with a friendly hop so there's a
runner at third with two out and
here is dj
got him swinging strike three back to
that slider that is not an easy man to
strike out he strikes out le mayhew and
that's the third strike out of the ball
game for morton well the braves have a
one-out walk followed by a one-out
single and they're at first and second
for dansby swanson hit on the ground a
third could be two go to second one on
the first double play
it's a five four three dp a shella to le
mayhew to mike ford so in the inning no
runs one hit
one left so judge goes to third torres
at first and here is mike ford just
called up today from the alternate site
with jay bruce retiring check swing he
went strike three and that ends the
yankee threat in the bottom of the
fourth inning front door breaking ball
out of charlie morton has been there all
night that's his fourth strikeout
charles morton has
been brilliant he is pitching a one hit
shutout through four well here is geo
orcello swung on and drilled to deep
center field back goes heredia on the
track at the wall she's gone
he hit the netting
protecting the retired numbers in dead
center geo eschela
he ties the game
geo eschela the most happy fella tell
you what that had that sound uh in tampa
bay he hit what 453 that had that same
sound dead center field
from rochelle
the sudden tie game with one swing of
the bat 437 feet it goes about 109 miles
an hour off the bat brett gardner struck
out flight out charlie morton delivers
got him with a breaking ball charlie
wins that battle
strikeout number five in his first one
since the fourth inning giancarlo
stanton who has struck out and walked
fastball got him looking stanton knew it
when he gets some blue birds
back-to-back strikeouts for charlie
gives him six grounded towards short
dansby waits for it now he's got it
quickly to first in time and a one two
three inning for charlie morton yankees
go quietly bottom of the order setting
the table a walk a single and now an
infield hit out of a radio right they
drove in the only braves run to this
point that was back in the third inning
swinging in the miss got a big strikeout
of audriones
well there's some history in this
matchup the lefty justin wilson against
freeman freeman one for seven but has
walked four times
and a walk here would do the job because
the bases are loaded heads shortly to
second base lamini goes to second gets
the force and wilson does the job the
only man the braves haven't gotten out
tonight is this guy and here it is from
aj
and it's lifted to shallow right now
coming over into foul ground freddie
freeman mixing over the shoulder catch a
tremendous play by freddie will make
that our truest play of the game a great
defensive gem not an easy play and he
made it look easy so darneau for two
raves have the leadoff man on for the
second straight inning over the mound
labor torres is one on the first it's a
double play
nice play by gleber
it wasn't it hard he corralled it
quickly stepped on the bag and threw in
the same motion the best part about that
is that lewis couldn't get his glove on
it mess it up
sometimes pitcher's just getting away a
little too high now hicks at second
lemay you at first so here's judge o for
two with a walk line drive base hit
right field
hicks will stop at third
adrianza fires into freeman so a base
hit for judge and the bases are loaded
nobody out so it'll be nate jones
against clint frazier bases loaded
nobody out
and that one's going to get past or no
here comes hits he'll score yankees lead
2-1 the runners move up the yankees take
a 2-1 lead on the wild pitch
jones threw the ball straight down
and darno just couldn't block it so
two-way with the bases loaded and here's
mike ford the pitch is high ball four so
ford knocks in a run
with his bases loaded walk
lemay who touches home plate the yankees
take a 3-1 lead had a couple good
advance and then you really took
advantage of some breaks that the
atlanta braves gave you a wild pitch and
now ball four with the bases loaded yeah
yankee rally right
yes you take anything right right take
it and run so now oralis chapman is
pitching on seven days rest
now what that means usually is he's got
great velocity but david it might affect
his location we'll have to see and the
yankees are within one out
of breaking their five-game losing
streak and the pitches popped up off
first foul ford near the stands ford
makes the catch
ball game over yankees win
[Applause]
yankees win
and boy did they need that win